hey everyone look I know a lot of you
fast forward any of these sort of cold
open Sometimes some of you don't some of
you do I ask that you don't uh really
glad to be with you I think I told you
tomorrow would be our last show and then
next Monday we would have a Christmas
special Christmas special is going to be
Wednesday we will be broadcasting
actually Monday and Tuesday but
exclusively on mug Club episodes of you
can't say that on YouTube because uh
this whole year there have been a lot of
things that we can't say and some of you
have missed it but look
we have a major announcement to make
tomorrow regarding mug club uh
what that announcement will be remains
to be seen I'm waiting on some
information so I just want to make sure
that we don't lose touch with any of you
go to mugclubforever.com don't enter
www.http any of that stuff just mugclub
forever.com sometimes I guess www
doesn't work in incognito mode just mug
Club forever.com no backslashes enter in
your email you will never receive an
email
aside from an update as to when if and
where
mug club uh ends up being
wherever that may be because we want to
do right by you look they're sponsors
there's been all that what matters is
you you are what makes this show happen
you are the reason that this show is
uncancelable
and we are funded entirely by you mug
Club period
if you don't sign up you don't punch
your name in mug Club ceases to be all
the free content ceases to be you know
that we know that we never want to be
there with a charity with our handout we
want to provide you with something we've
tried to provide you with something for
many years uh that you actually want to
watch and I don't know how many of you
there are that's the thing I only know
there's at least 300 000 of you and if
you're watching the show you want to
continue watching that show go to
mugclub forever.com just enter in your
email
and we will make sure that if you have
been signed up timing issues we'll
figure it out do right by you I am
looking forward to
much bigger better things exciting new
developments mugclub forever.com nothing
else matters but you and us doing right
by you uh speaking of doing right by you
oh crap uh I guess everything's going
woke now and we have the exclusive
they're redoing Charlie Brown I guess
this is the woke version
everything I touch turns into a disaster
I guess I don't know what Christmas is
all about
isn't there anyone who knows what
Christmas is all about sure Charlie
Brown I can tell you what Christmas is
all about
[Music]
lights please Christmas is just another
excuse for white Christian capitalists
to shove their wealth and religion in
the faces of marginalized people it has
nothing to do with the birth of Jesus
who wasn't even born on December 25th
your Christmas isn't the only holiday
Charlie Brown what about Hanukkah
Kwanzaa where is the school place to
celebrate Yule or the Hallmark movies
wishing everyone a merry winter solstice
how about the Diwali Festival of Lights
you never heard of the Diwali festival
of lights did you don't get me started
on the Salvation Army all this because
America is a quasi-religious
anti-lgbtq AIP oligarchy where Christmas
is thrust upon us and Everyone Falls for
materialism each year like the good
little Mindless sheep they are and they
follow their Shepherd Donald Trump
[Music]
that's what Christmas is all about you
CIS white male
oh brother
[Music]
.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
father
s
[Music]
sipping from that mug as a you know at
least 300 something thousand New Mud
clubforever.com so glad to be with you
we have so much to get to today uh let
me just give you a rundown AOC I don't
know if you know this just crushed at
the box office really talking about that
yeah the Chinese military is a joke
sorry military
and that's just a start for what you can
expect hey
viewers like you
uh reichu and uh we also have look the
Twitter files have been dumped right
we've talked about that we've kind of
gone through them each piece you can go
back to the episodes check all the
references at ladder with crowder.com
but there's a character there Joel Roth
who has been in charge uh let's not use
the terminology that they make up in
charge of content moderation in charge
of determining who gets the platform who
gets banned and of course this person
has been given the boot they are no
longer there uh they don't want you to
say this on YouTube this is someone who
actually so I won't use the words like
it rhymes with Boomer
but this person actually Not only was
involved with the Banning of Donald
Trump not only involved with the removal
of the hunter Biden laptop story but
advocated for underage young boys to be
on gay dating websites we have all the
receipts so we will be talking about all
of that and on Mud Club today and
exclusive uh the drag queens who are
invited to former Vice President Biden's
White House yeah that was delicious need
a fresh coat of paint on that one so let
me ask you this question of the day and
again the algorithms which are more
important now than ever so I ask that
you hit the like button you share it
comment below considering all the
backlash
that Joel Roth and I might accidentally
say Joel Romero just to be clear
they're nothing alike
[Laughter]
actually
if you don't know Yul Romero go and
Google yolomero gay Jesus it's one of
the best moments in sports ever they
didn't mean to say gay Jesus he just
sounded like he said okay he meant to
say gay Jesus so considering all the
backlash with Joel Roth and Twitter and
you may not know Joel Roth but you need
to a lot of people didn't know about
George Soros a long time ago let me ask
you what do you think is going to happen
Facebook Instagram YouTube
you think they're going to be more
cautious with what they decide to censor
moving forward comment below because I
can tell you this what you've discovered
about Twitter is Child's Play
it's absolutely Child's Play compared to
what goes on with Google and YouTube
Facebook I can't speak to that as much
Google and YouTube you know what I can
which by the way is really important to
let you know it's a live show Monday
through Thursday head on over to rumble
right now because some of the
information we'll be discussing they're
not going to like it over there in Palo
Alto I don't really know if it's Silicon
Valley is that Palo also close enough
it's part of it yeah maybe it's a subset
there you go sorry that was I've been
holding back for a while uh it's Child's
Play compared to what goes on right
there and they don't like it so head on
over to rumble you are all subscribed on
YouTube nothing would make me happier
than to see you all migrate over to
rumble I want to see the numbers go down
on YouTube go up on rubble and
subscriptions you have the choice Monday
through Thursday 10 a.m Eastern okay we
have more to get to geralda how are you
sir I'm doing well
what's the suspicion that was weird
doing well what did my club forever go
down is that I have no idea probably I'm
not thinking about that yesterday you
guys crashed it so just keep checking it
mud clubforever.com just enter in your
email that's it are you okay uh yeah we
just got a lot going on yes we do have a
lot going on so yeah some of which we
might discuss tomorrow depending on how
things go I think so correct yeah yeah
I'm allowed to say that you are allowed
to say that good how are you
[Laughter]
a lot of marbles a lot of marbles a lot
of marbles out there yes
I like that shirt yeah yeah all of them
ah let me let me here let's play Devil's
Advocate ask me about other marbles
yes yo what yes all the marbles and uh
you hear him you know him you love him
he's going to be in Syracuse New York
this weekend fastest man on his feet
Dave Linda how are you Ahoy good how
about you
you know you've already been through
this yeah this is this is remedial but
uh all right everyone on your face you
ready it's gonna I do have vertigo turns
out it's stress by the way I shouldn't
be coughing blood yeah the only reason I
made that joke yesterday was to piss you
off with you too I was just trying to
shoot I would make a terrible joke
yesterday just to get you pissed off at
you too oh at the band you two yes
because I said are you in a place called
vertigo
I just wanted to piss you off songs blow
and they're free we're on your iPhone
and you didn't know can you feel all the
screw in so I have to get that book for
you I forgot no don't no it's Christmas
Dave always gets me horrible gifts you
have a friend who does it'll get me like
a U2 sign and he'll he'll spend a lot of
money to get a gift that angers me they
knows I'm going to burn he gets it
Spencer yes no I mean I spent thousands
well he also gets a free uh PacSun girl
poster oh wow I get the plasma orb I
like Spencer so okay before we move on
Roth is what we are going to be
discussing today and I know you're
saying oh why do I care trust me this is
a key player over there at Twitter that
we need to discuss you need to know the
people who are in positions of power
again like we talked about yesterday
unelected people are more powerful and
unelected gay advocate of underage
children dating men of age
removed a sitting president
think about that
if you pick the power of Washington DC
over the power of Silicon Valley big
Tech and Hollywood you need a CAT scan
now speaking of people who've sort of
been led by the nose uh we have a clip
here a group of black nationalists
outside of the Barclay Center in
Brooklyn and before you look let's don't
go into the whole Kanye thing just just
listen to what they have to say first
and then when you understand the
historical context of Hitler it's kind
of hysterical here they are uh black
nationalists praising Kanye and Hitler
why don't I feel good about him
I'll talk mainly about cognac what about
Kanye
and he's crazy you're half Jewish yes
and he's raising Hitler saying the Nazis
are cool and sing the Holocaust
all of you
know who the real juice was
coming for your next holy [ __ ] right it
kind of was
right you're the you're the seed of the
devil man right these brothers
shaking things up it's because Awakening
happy birthday a real Jews oh back on
the streets
whose identity are going to go into
slavery
right did the Holocaust happen
a bit there's a lot to like having
Christmas already
there's a lot to unpack there but never
mind not much that was insane it's it's
pretty straightforward here's the thing
I mean not the craziest thing I've heard
on the street in New York no absolutely
not well the craziest thing I've heard
is that uh you know I'm Jesus
but it's always the homeless guy like
peeing down you know the sewer drain
it's never the guy making copies yeah
it's true you're like I'm Jesus like
really oh that's what you did this
weekend so just to be clear Hitler uh
wherever you line up on this let's say
you really don't like Jews if you're a
black nationalist of either Black Hebrew
Israelite
Hitler was oppressing your people Hitler
wanted to kill all of your people unless
your people were blonde hair and blue
eyes here's what Hitler wrote In My Mind
Comfort regarding blacks everybody
except that yes exact brand of person
and he was exempt yep Jews Jews were
responsible for bringing Negroes into
the Rhineland and with the ultimate idea
of bastardizing the white race which is
a hate and zus lowering its cultural and
political level so that the Jew might
dominate
reading as Hitler people
which is a good choice the mulatto
children came about Sue rape or the
white mother was a [ __ ] in both cases
there is not the slightest moral duty
regarding this offspring of a foreign
race just to be clear blacks couldn't
attend University or public schools
under Hitler and by the way uh black
white children were forcibly sterilized
if they were of mixed race so Hitler
wasn't oppressing my people
ah okay you're not going to understand
this answer I'm glad I got rid of Dr
Seuss yes I'm glad you have a platform
and all kinds of people supporting you
out in public and by people supporting
them you mean nobody no I mean the guy's
standing around him I like the guy who's
Jewish he goes yeah I'm half Jewish he
says he goes all of you think that yeah
where did I walk in he's like all of you
think the Holocaust was a good thing you
should probably run the other way person
maybe it's because people are stupid and
reactionary yeah that could be it let's
just be honest that's what it is they're
uneducated they don't know what they're
talking about so they're going out and
they people are very angry and that's
what they do they want to direct their
anger at somebody and this is the result
of it when you don't actually research
something you're supporting somebody who
wanted you dead look it up and stop
being stupid which is funny because I
also don't understand how it makes sense
like he wasn't oppressing my people well
you mean black people but I'm the real
Jew well then he we're right back to
this is just yes wait hold on a second
you mean he said that he wasn't
depressing black people which he was or
he wasn't oppressing the true Jews which
you claim to be that you you are but you
what are you saying I'm saying Jesus was
a Jew well that we can agree on
if you're saying genuine Jews he hated
yes and you're genuinely Jew yes uh I
see oh okay perhaps a megaphone's not
for you yes perhaps the microphone is
not for you or even a stoop yes they
have a padded cell yeah I don't think
you necessarily here's the thing several
quran's not the only book they should
have in prison yes exactly I don't know
why it comes with a face tattoo kit ah
uh I know no tattoos in his arm but tell
that to Mike Tyson I I like I worship
Outlaw but I also want to put a tribal
tattoo on my faith and make Orphans of
your children I don't know how this
works here's the thing um
look let's just assume that there are
people out there who dislike uh Jewish
people who believe that there's this
cabal of Jewish people who control
everything and we've talked about this
in the show let's assume that you're one
of those people who believes that and I
disagree and you believe something
reprehends okay
you can also be anti-semitic and
understand that Hitler also hated black
people
the two are not mutually exclusive in
other words you could be a black person
and be anti-semitic or you could be
racist but you still have to acknowledge
the historical reality that Hitler
didn't like black people or you didn't
like anyone who was an Aryan and the
funniest part about that is that if you
think about it the Japanese believe they
were the superior race they believe they
were the superior pan-Asian race they
even thought that the Chinese Were A
different race and if you want to
believe in cruelty see what the Japanese
and the Chinese did to each other during
those conflicts they thought they were
the superior race they were part of the
axis of Evil with the Nazis who believe
that the Aryans were the superior race
at the end of that war if they had won
that would have been a hell of an
awkward tiebreaker yes it would have
I'm so glad we're down to the superior
race yes they're correct
oh you're still here
[Music]
well I guess let's settle this with the
game of try and reach the top shelf oh
no I guess I thought
I believe they were the Superior race
it's ridiculous okay this brings us to
speaking of people who aren't fear not
because of race no but for intellectual
reasons AOC
AOC
Acacia Cortez for the uninitiated has a
new documentary out about climate change
debuted this week to um rave reviews and
surprisingly a huge box office a huge
box office success
fighting for change politically requires
faith
we are building an army of young people
to stop the climate crisis and create
millions of good jobs for Our Generation
we're in the battle for the soul of the
democratic party make them feel like
they're going to lose their seats if
they don't support this as long as there
are people that you can poison without
consequence there will always be a
loophole that the fossil industry can
exploit
it's possible to both decarbonize and
keep equity and Justice at the center
your
that's when they want you to think
you're
the flow
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
can you rewind that just a couple
seconds was that was that a close-up of
a woman vaping Club is a steam in front
of why do they include that in there
play that again
what is that
I don't think that's good for the
environment
can I go back a couple frames I didn't
notice that one look what is this why
are they showing that is that just image
noise expert you can comment is that
image noise or are they like yeah let's
appeal to The Vaping crowd it's probably
an Overlook they're overlaying the face
with like fire it could just be meth
smoke could just be meth smoke well
there could be yeah you know what zits
and a nose ring yes someth sores saying
maybe it's cold outside and she's
breathing yeah yeah well I'm pretty sure
it's cold inside
sorry we're talking about the soul hey
by the way uh also according to Rolling
Stone look credit where it's due it's
been the most successful film this year
even beating out uh Top Guns Maverick so
wait really yeah yeah we have to give
credit where it's where it's due uh wow
yeah
yeah
what did I say that's it most successful
oh sorry I'm at least successful
I meant the opposite yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry you
can admonish me I was wrong I said most
successful yes no aoc's documentary is
the least successful there you go
made less than ten thousand dollars
that's under eighty dollars per screen
enough for the staff hey but the good
news is it has an 83 fresh score on
Rotten Tomatoes so that's good so the
critics like it possible and they're the
only ones who have seen it yeah
we have some exclusive footage from uh
aoc's film premiere
[Applause]
it's the most horrible thing I've ever
seen in my life 83
he was one of the 17 yes yes I love that
every crappy movie has a 100 rating on
Rotten I know that's just amazing you
weren't a fan of Nanette oh no yes I'm
going to tell jokes by not telling jokes
imagine brilliant turning comedy on its
head you mean by not doing comedy
the light turns blue and I was raped six
times uh-huh uh-huh well this is good
stuff yes
wrong credits whoa wow a word to blame
that we're not enjoying this okay oh I
see it's white man's fault yes exactly
speaking of which uh we're to blame uh
over the fact that the Chinese military
is a joke
so this is something this is important
China has tried to and like we said we I
said this a while back we called it
Russia everyone thought they were this
intimidating military this military
force if nothing else from Ukraine
Russia wherever it is that you line up
wherever you're watching this it has
shown us that the Russian military is
nowhere near as powerful as they wanted
us to think I said I bet the same thing
would happen with China I get they have
a lot of people but you can only toss
bodies at a wall like it's World War Z
for so long until you run out of people
so China has been trying to make sure
that you believe and then we'll have a
clip of what actually happens I'll power
you believe in its powerful military
here's some of their propaganda videos
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are they advertising like you have a
choice yeah exactly why advertise yeah
it's like you're gonna go there anyway
it's like people advertise milk yeah huh
sure right if you're going to want it
you're gonna just buy it join a military
what if I don't want to no no no no no I
have to then why do an ad and spend
money yeah
make you feel better yeah make you feel
better can we take you from family
we have tank like five so that image
that you just saw uh just came crashing
down yesterday because there was uh
there was basically a conflict with the
Chinese military and then Indian troops
yeah and what you're about to see is
real not edited totally real contrast
that with the Chinese military these are
not protesters facing off against Indian
troops at the border
[Music]
[Laughter]
resupply at ski resort
and she sees it I don't know hockey oh
no they're getting badminton racket run
for life
oh vault
well actually that could be pretty good
weapons yeah I understand that they
don't have them sharpened yeah exactly
the first guy who goes whack with a
stick I'm like ow bang like
how do you not walk through the dead
yeah so China's blaming India India is
blaming China by the way this is the
first sort of Border encounter between
the two I guess since 2020
um and of course what's what's not funny
is there were people killed I mean and
by the way the worst part is they must
have been killed over a very significant
portion of time if that's how the
conflict yeah I was gonna say that's the
I think it was more such Civil War was a
further apart battle success yes when
you get killed by a stone in battle
today it's got to be just a little bit
embarrassing a little you get to heaven
and it's like well how did you die did
he die well he was hit by a stick 4 000
times but wasn't he wearing a helmet
yeah that's why I said four thousand
yeah the hitting with the stick was
largely irrelevant yeah he was
dehydrated yeah he eventually just shot
himself yes he had a gun this whole time
that's what we thought yeah we didn't
know grenades as well didn't use any of
it he always he wanted to go out on his
stick mostly blanks it's all stick
fighting these days kids oh boy and it
should be noted by the way the Chinese
they've been about the Chinese uh
culture milit they've been embellishing
the strength for a long time right
including skills that they claim go back
thousands of years like the art of kung
fu
[Music]
Jah
watch your eyes yes
wow it was so fast wow the death touch
didn't work
that's odd what about having your legs
around him just didn't stop him from
breaking your arms yes what about this
Punch remember it can stop the heart yes
the one inch punch the one inch punch
yeah you know what you fail to account
it Bruce Lee Bruce Lee Mammoth man five
foot seven one thirty two giant all
power 132 pound one inch the point is
this don't believe everything the media
is telling you and don't you miss the
one period of time in the United States
under Donald Trump when we said hey you
know what maybe China's not the great
big threat that we thought they were and
they're only a threat if we build them
up into that threat
for the first time they started playing
ball with Donald J with Donald J Trump
president Trump no no no he mean what he
say he crazy
now right away they're back to conflicts
he had lots of sticks they're back to
warning us they're back to just like we
just traded uh Brittany we traded a
black lesbian uh who can't go one week
without her hash oil for the merchant O
Death because Russia decided they were
going to give us an ultimatum do you
feel like you're in a stronger position
yes but she can dunk yes by the way hit
the like button of course if you're
watching right now on YouTube that helps
with the algorithm head on over to
rumble
um I wore something oh from just today
special for you Stephen so die hard is
it what do you think Bruce Willis said
it's not so brothers
that's fair hold on but we do have some
exclusive footage that I think you need
to see what yeah you could just watch
this I don't know about this okay it is
so disgraceful Die Hard technically a
Christmas movie so we thought we'd
shoehorn that in yeah
oh
you lose
it is
these are the words you're just saying
look the writer said it was sometimes I
lie oh come on
if I feel like I'm gonna lie I feel uh I
lied I feel Vindicated uh it is a
Christmas movie Why Bruce Willis said it
wasn't but he also has a googly God
brain yes he does
can't trust anything yes he does I'd be
like pouring out a conch that's been in
the Sun for too long uh so hit the like
button so this also brings us by the way
as we're discussing this uh Joel Roth is
the person we really want to get to and
it's but they're it's pretty granular so
I know it's nerdy but we're going to put
it in a way that you can hopefully
understand it does directly affect you
because this person has been directly uh
helping an act policy that affects you
but uh this week of course we have uh
former Vice President Joe Biden he uh
enjoyed a lot of moments uh he got lost
he got cut off during his own voiceover
he thought it was the voice of God to be
fair yeah that's true calling him to the
light and uh something about his
favorite chips being so you know what
this week in Biden let's watch it if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump then you ain't
black
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's what people are finding out
is what what all marriages what they're
rude or about or whether their marriages
of lesbians or gay men or heters
it will construct a second fab here in
Phoenix to build chips three Nano chips
the three Nano chip chips that are three
Nano and you know what I'm saying
Nano no no I don't know oh wait if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're from me or Trump and you ain't
black okay president Mork
[ __ ] all he has is mini strokes I know
Nano
championing and by the way you can say
I'm not unforgiving if someone says I
mean to say uh you know when I mean to
say three o'clock sorry I meant to say
four Eastern you know what I'm saying
that's where the appropriate answer is
yes right no one knew what he was saying
yeah so the appropriate response was the
laughter that you heard yes do you know
what I'm saying
no but we're all very scared yes why
would you sacrifice a child to leave him
off stage don't be that sacrificial
children child that's that's like okay
hey you're gonna have to go and uh lead
the president yeah I get smelled he may
touch you he may tell you not to get
married until 30 there's a lot of things
that can happen he's like one of those
creepy posters where the eyes follow you
only it's exclusive to girls who are
seven oh
or eight so uh let's get in here to uh
Joel Roth and by the way mugclub
forever.com go in punch in your email
just punch in your email that's it
mugclubforever.com right now bring It Up
full screen there to them in go to
mudclubforever.com we don't want to lose
touch with you you'll receive no emails
aside from when where and you know how
mug Club returns we want to do right by
you there's no way for me to reach you
if you don't enter in your email we'll
give you more of an announcement
tomorrow let's get to Joel Roth so we
have more of these Twitter files that
have been made public uh I don't know
here everyone who has read it I had to
read through it a lot and this name kept
popping up y'all Roth y'all Roth you'll
Roth okay he's Twitter's former head of
trust and safety
and I'll go through the top five uh I
guess sort of most egregious misdeeds
from him but uh you know this is a guy
who was responsible for a lot of sins I
mean chief amongst them Banning the
president he helped censor the hunter
Biden laptop story obviously he went
after conservatives he colluded with uh
our intelligence agencies not to mention
the fact that he's a huge pervert what
do I mean by that I mean sexual deviant
who's okay with grown men having sex
with minors who happen to be men the gay
thing is not my Pro is not my problem
there it's the it's the pedophilia oh
it's the yeah the mind the minor thing
yeah yeah that's my primary gripe yeah
that would be the main issue exactly I
think we're all on the same page that
brings us to the latest installment
which we can do because we're
demonetized of what a piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
okay so to get a sense of I missed that
Stinger that's a good one to have it is
yeah I missed that Stinger it's perfect
for this it is absolutely perfect and it
was for Don Lemon as well we did it in
the past enough yeah that's true
hopefully you know it's always nice when
you know the conservatives of course
have your have your back and they
understand that you should be
demonetized that's true yeah they get it
on board right I'm charging the hill
with you yeah yeah so to get a sense of
who uh Roth is
here's a clip from him about a week ago
uh whining about how terrified he is of
of uh and keep in mind the context the
former vice president not too long ago
said that Maga Republicans were
extremists here is the head of Twitter
and safety talking about his fear of
Maga Bros it's terrifying I thought I
was going to be a college professor for
a living I like I got a PhD and was
doing research that nobody cared about
and uh and then I was like oh you know
like this platform thing is cool like I
can go and do research there and and
then you know one thing led to another
and all of a sudden we apply a
misinformation label to Donald Trump's
account and I'm on the cover of the New
York Post and that is a deeply
terrifying experience and I say this
from a position of
unquestioned privilege as a CIS white
male like the internet is much scarier
and much worse for lots of other people
who aren't me but it was pretty [ __ ]
scary for a long time as a result of
that scariest part his reflection now it
wasn't in the mirror exactly he said he
was a CIS white male yeah CIS means
you're not trans
he's gay you can be CIS and gay is that
true you can also have a gay cyst it's
from it's really a friction burn now
more of a Fisher it can be a CIS gay man
yes oh
am I the only one who pays attention to
the nonsense these days no I but CIS
means you are not trans right yeah it's
a synonym okay what we once referred to
as normal or regular
oh it's like if all of a sudden we
started calling Coca-Cola classic Cisco
yes you don't need to specify that it's
Coke you specify if it's Diet Coke you
specify if it's gay if it's trans you
don't need to specify if they're a
heterosexual you don't need the term CIS
so if a Coke
has sex with other Coke if a Coke has
sex with Diet Coke it's just standard
Coke right I would have had sex with
regular Coke it could still be standard
Coke provided it's not a Coke who
identifies a Sprite let me move on I
understand okay
now that you put it it's going to take a
while unless it's Pepsi yes well then
it's 10 minutes yeah then it's an
Abomination yeah we go back to Leviticus
we're back to Hitler's mulatto yes
don't get him started on Pepsi clear
albinos all right so this brings us to
the top five reasons that Joel Roth is a
piece of human excrement all reference
available at lottery.com number five
okay and we'll do this in ascending
order with intensity Roth you'll Roth
has a deeply rooted hatred for
conservatives which of course is the
problem if you're supposed to be in
charge of trust and say trust trust
let's say trust not to mention safety I
don't know if you know this I've had a
few safety scares myself right right you
ever been on the Isis kill list
fun place you ever been on their
frequent flyer list I feel like I'm on
it now
also the IRS sorry about that no that
that started when I got here yes so head
of Twitter trust and safety
hate it let me let me give you the
receipt so in 2016 election day this is
what Roth tweeted I'm just saying we fly
over those states that voted for a
racist Tangerine for a reason oh boy hey
any of your users live in those States
these people hate you these people hate
you you need to start understanding
these people hate you it's not this is
why I like Dunkin Donuts I've talked
about it Dunkin Donuts is not political
the coffee's better than Starbucks
they've said we will not enter into
politics all their charity work that
they do I don't know if it's Meals on
Wheels or they do like you know families
in need they give them Christmas baskets
they do Big Brother program that's
enough for me I don't care about your
personal politics if you don't actively
hate me with my money this man is
employed through your dollars if you
visit Twitter and then craps on your
state and your beliefs and removes
people with your beliefs here we go to
2017. he was responding to critics of
the the women's March for those who
don't remember the [ __ ] hat a
family-friendly Affair tweeted this yes
that person in the pink hat is clearly a
bigger threat to your brand of feminism
than actual Nazis in the white house I
think you meant to say actual Nazis at
the Barclay Center yes
is in the white house so it's just a
little insight into how he views Donald
Trump is if we had any questions about
how he was going to handle him when we
get down to a Numero Uno at the end here
yeah yeah one this is a problem too is
where you have people like the the Kanye
West of the world and look there's a lot
I disagree with you know president Trump
but if you're going to call him a Nazi
and then the other people are going to
hate him because of his relationship
with Jared Kushner like there's no
pleasing conservatives need to be clear
about this you can disagree with someone
on one point this guy says You're a Nazi
oh wow there are a lot of Jews in his
cabinet they're Jews in his family for
crying out loud and not to mention the
little fact that he actively and vocally
condemned Nazis where's the
misinformation tweet oh that's right
this guy's in charge of it yeah also
Nazis is a completely pointless loser
term that people use just to sound like
something's bad right that's why I say
stalinist
filthy pinko's telling us I say silly
boy do you yeah well it's just a synonym
for staliness because we know what
you're really saying like a silly boy in
the White House I say silly boy because
I can't say what he actually is
he's a Jew
so uh here's another issue by the way uh
here he is discussing censoring a tweet
these are from the Twitter dumps uh
representative Matt Getz Roth head of
Twitter trust and safety said it doesn't
quite fit anywhere but I'm trying to
talk safety into treating it as
incitement I think we'll get it over the
line for removal as a conspiracy that
incites violence which tweet is it can
you bring up what that tweet is people
can see it I think yeah
this one from Michael schellenberger oh
okay it's for Michael he also did one
with Matt Getz uh you guys in the
control room here you can bring that to
us I don't have it in front of me uh by
the way hit that like button comment
below how familiar you are with Joel
Roth and if you think that what you I'm
really I don't see any losing scenario
for Elon Musk Elon Musk taking over
Twitter no no absolutely not by the way
what he's saying here is just going back
to that this is the same thing that we
dealt with with uh the vagina correctly
because it's just yeah it's a little
close to a vagina Gap nope vagina
she's basically doing the same thing
here Roth is saying hey we I'm gonna
make this fit so that we can get rid of
them not that hey this content does
violate our policies not that this is a
clear violation we should do it I'm
going to make this fit I think we're
going to get over the line it's like
you're just you're just doing what you
want to do yeah no it's trying to find
it and then they accuse people on the
right of being biased look I am biased
just to be clear yeah I've always been
very very clear about my bias I make all
the references available liveclutter.com
I want you to fact check me I want you
to do your own research nobody else in
this industry does that every single
reference you see you can then go and
read in its entirety because I know I'm
biased what are my biases I believe that
men and women are a thing I don't
believe it's a figment of your
imagination I tend to believe that the
government does things poorly in
relation to people's individual
decisions I tend to believe in freedom
of speech and I hate communists
let's bring you to reason number four
that Roth is a piece of crap
wow that's good Roth actually colluded
so he hates conservatives
people say that it's extreme for us to
say we need to disband the FBI yeah we
need to disband our intelligence and by
the way that has nothing to do with
their local police uh law enforcement so
I'm getting to the point not being a
huge fan of police in general if you
enforce these rules from the top down I
was just doing my job is not enough we
need more cops and we certainly need
more people in the FBI CIA DHS we need
all of you speaking out
so he colluded with American Intel to
Target
conservatives who he didn't like here's
an internal message Roth referred to as
quote weekly sync and what that refers
to is he would have meetings with the
FBI uh DHS and the Director of National
Intelligence and another message here's
what Roth actually wrote he was
complaining about how difficult it was
to conceal these meetings on his
calendar
talk about a persecution gosh I'm
meeting with the FBI and CIA meeting
with them to try and ban conservatives
but is there a way like to put an
incognito mode
it's getting so hard it's getting
difficult where's the child this is what
he said I reached a certain point where
my meetings became very interesting to
people and there weren't meeting names
generic enough to cover here's what a
co-worker said very boring business
meeting that definitely is not about
Trump to which Roth responded
pretty much definitely not meeting with
the FBI I swear what a piece of [ __ ]
what a piece of [ __ ] just to be clear
think about this this guy who has never
been elected to office and also isn't it
telling it before this he was going to
become a professor hey I was going to
wield my power over your children which
we'll get to he wants them to date
professors I was going to use my power
to wield and I wield it over an
unwilling audience your children for
eight hours a day but instead when I was
offered a better I decided to wield my
completely unearned power unelected
power against the leaders of the Free
World and half of the citizens of the
greatest country on Earth
[Music]
open my face how many times do you think
you think when he heard that Elon Musk
had purchased Twitter and would have
accesses and I'm not just talking about
Lou sphincter
that's 100 a real problem this guy
imagine him pushing back at all he would
never push back on the FBI well he's
weak he would never do that he'd never
say hey uh we need you to censor this
okay yeah we can do well we'll we'll
find a way within our policy yeah we'll
find a way within our policies what is
there to gain I don't understand
yeah for who it's collusion with them
install a former vice president
make sure that people don't know the
truth whether they go into an election
make sure the people only hear one side
of the story if you control 100 of the
information that people get guess what
you can control how people vote you can
control how people think it's hey you
have enough of these people for enough
amount of guess what there are plenty of
societies in which child brides are
still a thing
more slaves than ever on record
recording history now on Earth over 40
million because a lot of them are sex
slaves they don't have a problem with it
just to be not saying this guy is
advocating for sexual slavery what I'm
saying is you many of you believe that
values are Universal they are not people
like this who are trying to subvert
Western Society know that values aren't
Universal and so if they can time over
time over chip chip chip chip chip away
at it they can get you to believe
anything they want to sell which brings
us and it's a valid question because you
are actually a decent man you wouldn't
think of lying in order to get the
American public to be accepting of I
think I can use the word pederasty yeah
that's exactly right so uh here's
another reason number three that he's a
piece of human excrement
I like it he's a pervert that adds the
serious it does yeah he's an absolute
pervert so this isn't just hearsay I
should say this let me be clear I think
I think he's a sexual deviant okay I
also think after getting into him that
he is personal opinion I can't declare
it you can label this misinformation if
you want
just to be clear all right
so here's why I think so 2010 you'll
Roth posted a link to a story titled can
high school students ever meaningfully
consent to sex with their teachers
spoiler alert maybe you can go read it
2012 Roth tweeted out I enjoy having the
kinds of meetings where Googling quote
gay bareback porn is considered academic
work
[Music]
2015
Roth actually uh wrote this regards it
regarding the future of porn at Twitter
quote Twitter will live to porn another
day thing I just yell out loudly at work
unbelievable all right so so these These
are the tweets on his personal account
do you know that he had a secret dirty
account not kidding not making this up
dirtier dirty herb well he called it his
dirty account for him this is normal
everyday language
he had a silly boy account it was called
utterific autorific at utterific so if
anybody I feel like you're saying that
flippantly nope and Otter probably means
something horrible it really does I
don't know I'm just saying oh that was
Auto worker that made perfect sense yes
it's probably sick and disgusting his
name is my name too cannot comprehend I
see but that account and all of the
tweets have been wiped really so what
we're hoping why are you telling me
about this I've been doing research for
the last 48 hours why don't you telling
me well how do I not know about a river
I'm just saying he made a couple of
comments in some of his tweets about
having this other account and there's
some really interesting tweets that all
right send it to us control room but I'm
just it's yeah it's been taken down so
they can see if they can find it and
Otter is a gay man who is very Harry
Oliver's Body but a smaller in frame and
weighs considerably less than a bear
that doesn't make any sense otters are
smooth
well that is weird I mean I get there
I've met certainly are I
mammal so technically there's hair do
you think of otters as hairy yeah no I
no yeah I get it I just thought of him
as cute yes I've never touched an otter
to be honest and Santa Claus is coming
to town he says he's as slippery it's a
seal which is let's just be honest it's
another otter yeah I thought a seal was
yeah it's just a bigger otter I know
they're not the same thing I don't know
we think he's dirty on this he he
creates an entirely separate account so
he can let his freak flag fly like
that's what this guy's doing yeah well
here's something else again why I think
he's a sexual deviant yeah
now those are tweets and you can say ah
people drunk tweet all the time sure you
can tell by the typos
here's his PhD thesis
was titled gay data
and in it he said that miners should be
he advocated for minors to be on gay
dating websites oh here's some quotes
it's worth considering how if at all the
current generation of popular sites of
gay network sociability might fit into
an overall queer social landscape that
increasingly includes individuals under
the ages of 18. minors yeah read that as
minors individuals under the age that
you're saying I get it yo miners I think
individuals under the age of 18 sounds
worse yeah yeah I think it sounds worse
whatever focus group you ran sucks could
you hire Frank Luntz and his stupid
sneakers and toupee also I love the way
that he tries to sound smart by the
words he chose yeah he just sounds like
a bigger [ __ ] idiot part of my
language oh my God and he forgets to put
a plural on the word things yeah I think
Hmm sorry um
rather than merely trying to absolve
themselves of legal responsibility or
worth trying to drive out teenagers
entirely which we know means teenagers
under 18.
service provides providers should
instead on Crafting safety strategies
that can accommodate a wide variety of
use cases for platforms like Grindr
including possibly their role in safely
connecting queer young adults I don't
know why he sounds like the dentist from
I'm going to be a queer dentist
we don't know need any homo dolls stop
trying to have sex with kids yes I would
say that is it that hard grinder is a
difficult that's all it is it's a hookup
app do whatever you want as an adult
stop yeah why is this so prevalent oh
and why do you think they hate
conservatives and hated Donald Trump so
much this guy buried the hunter laptop
story leave our kids alone it's
seriously just disgusting it's
absolutely I'm so tired of seeing it
it's non-stop every time they leak one
of these things out about any of these
guys anything it always involves child
it's it's disgusting on every level
that's absolutely disgusting this is
also why it's important that we're able
to talk about look I get that this is
not a pleasant topic oh no I'm not
saying that I'm no no I get it but I'm
saying to people out there look they
can't discuss us at church we've talked
about this in the past pastors go out
and go this is why I have a problem as a
Christian going to church and they'll
say oh you know there's evil out there
why don't you name it why don't you name
it the evil the Lord will you're
speaking generalities
how about the head of Twitter trust and
safety advocating for advocating for
pederasty advocating for sex with
children and then they'll be offended
that we address the evil that we live
look we'll have people on the right who
don't acknowledge the evil and then you
have the people engaging in the evil and
we're kind of in that in between I'm
sorry it offends you this person's a
degenerate but your college thesis is
based on how to make social media uh
able to connect adults and children to
have sex so you get hired at a social
media company to be in charge of safety
just want to make sure oh yeah that's
clear that's some pretty good
foreshadowing because it's going to come
back oh good we are going to bring this
Tugboat back to shore oh I just wanted
to make sure that I heard that right and
I want to make sure that you don't have
an aneurysm because it looks bad can I
have a gun yeah well we have plenty but
no if you kill yourself with anything
other than a Walther I don't have a
sponsorship I don't think he wants to
kill himself
we have someone retweeting one of the
autorific tweets oh boy he said muscle
bear with beard hot yeah muscle bear
with beard holding a child inexplicably
hotter holding a child muscle bear
holding it this is one of the tweets
that I saw somebody else retweet how
about that okay don't take this as a
threat of violence if that is confirmed
and that is real someone's saying
holding a child is hotter that's someone
who if they're ever near my children is
getting their ass kicked is that okay is
that is that okay does that offend you
more than a guy saying he's sexually
aroused by a hairy gay man holding a
child
he's getting the [ __ ] kicked out of him
and we're at a point where we're people
are afraid of being demonetized they're
afraid of being removed if we say hey
hey hey you want to sexualize Children
you got an ass beating coming your way
how about how about this we'll give him
an I'll give you an renounce it renounce
the [ __ ] you just said about being
about being aroused about it being
erotic
in a sexual context with a child if you
don't renounce it
if there aren't severe consequences for
people like this and I mean I mean with
the proper legal system or if they're
around the child they shouldn't be
allowed within 100 yards of a child
electrocution yep
lethal injection right joking but like a
bunch of Home Alone things how about
that yes yeah except you know you know
how it really works when you're hit with
a paint cam yeah
you just you just play the sound of
children frolicking they put their sound
of a tortoise but you can't coming down
the playground stairs
you can't even pretend that there was
something weird like but it's like a
good father it's this it no it's you
saying hotter because you're a pervert
because you're a pervert and this is
also the problem with so many people
being able to hide their identities
and by the way mud clubforever.com
because God only knows what happens
other people have to tiptoe around it
including by the way we're not just
talking about liberals
hopefully conservatives are ready out
there to charge the hill I don't want to
see a conservative movement where you're
concerned about being demonetized we're
concerned about being removed and we we
can't have any kind of conservative
movement where they're the enforcement
arm of big Tech because they tell you
that we're not allowed to say what we
just said I don't think it's all that
controversial you sexualize children
you're a criminal isn't she about to say
something yeah so that was in response
that tweet was in response to something
he had posted about having a hotter
profile picture which means he's saying
this is hot the profile picture you're
posting you'll is hotter this isn't just
him commenting that that's hotter it's
saying hey yo I see that you just posted
another profile picture it's actually
hotter than it was before because Joel
was actually on his honorific saying I
just posted a much hotter picture for my
profile like could we just read the
response or was that we just read the
response response what was it that he
said so that's what that's what's not
available anymore
so we can read the responses yeah yeah
there's got to be a way to read the way
back there's got to be I hope Elon
seriously digs out there's got to be a
way to oh Elon knows because Elon made
the comment about Joel and he started
all this is what brings it so true so
during Roth's time at Twitter this is
and Elon talked about this child porn
was a huge problem we just had this last
week and this time security was running
it yeah Elon Musk said to a tweet about
child porn on Twitter it is a crime that
they refused to take action on child
exploitation for years and then he had
Jack Dorsey claiming that the story was
false Elon replied when Ella Irwin who
now runs trust and safety joined Twitter
earlier this year almost no one was
working on child safety I made it top
priority immediately now I know what
people are going to say on the left
because they want to obfuscate he got
rid of the department that had trust and
safe no he got rid of the trust and
safety department so he could actually
enforce the laws regarding child
pornography because of the trust and
safety department allows child
pornography while throttling the hunter
Biden laptop story it ceases to serve
any relevance so that's the switch they
try and tell you Elon Musk got rid of
the child trust and say he's a long
child no no no no he is going after and
has been publicly attacking previous
heads of councils at Twitter for
abetting child pornography and he's
putting his money where his mouth is
this is really important don't let
people fool you into believing that Elon
shut down that department now here's
here's what happens right that being
number one and that's what he made it it
should have been number one before and
it's why he made it number one now yes
that should be the top priority of any
security for an Internet site I would
assume for a social media site yes
absolutely you should you deserve the
full brunt of the law if you do not get
rid of child pornography on social media
I would think hey if this is the whole
myth of common ground
we talk about we talk about kids who
come here and there's no fault of their
own what about dreamers and they should
go okay we should get a citizenship hold
on a second but before we get to Common
Ground hey what about getting what about
saying child porn is bad
well I would say it but my college
thesis that oh no Common Ground I have
plenty of friends I could use a few
enemies screw you now here's the thing
Elon Musk went after Twitter for this
he was very public about it I just read
you the tweets right now let me ask you
this
this is a tweet it is a crime that they
refuse to take action on child
exploitation for years
okay
does that sound like a threat does that
sound like a call to violence no no
because guess who gets to play the
victim Roth because even though he's a
white CIS male Elon Musk is a white
heterosexual CIS males here we go back
to that and so he said that he may have
to he had to flee his home due to what
CNN described again CNN is in this
incestuous relationship as quote an
escalation in threats resulting not Elon
Musk resulting from musk's campaign of
criticism against him you mean there's
been an escalation of threats resulting
from Elon musk's campaign of criticizing
someone who actively promoted and wrote
a thesis on supporting child pornography
we feel bad for the child porn guy
you out you wanted to oust Clarence
Thomas because he made a joke about a
pube on his can of Coke and it was a
very funny joke all of America wrote
down in their journals he told a funny
joke today this guy's telling people
that child porn should be acceptable and
we're supposed to feel bad for him
come on guys there's not going to be a
civilization left to protect unless you
put your foot down look behind you
that's where you were supposed to hold
the line we're not looking to get
removed from YouTube we're not looking
to get removed from Big Tech but if it
means speaking out against a child porn
Peddlers all references available a lot
of credit.com I am willing to accept the
results please go to mudclub forever.com
mugclub forever.com Bring It Up full
screen there Tillman mudkipforever.com
we don't want to lose touch with you
have some major announcements coming
forward
but the leash is off completely I don't
give a rat's ass how much does offends
somebody oh don't you feel like you
should no no
I'm out of compassion to give the second
you sexualize kids that's it you're an
enemy renounce it has he renounced it
he's renounced it hasn't renounced it
yet right by the way you don't get to
play the victim card when all that's
been done and by the way you know CNN
wanted to use harsher language than this
his campaign of criticism
he's critiquing his work Santa just had
a producer who was what was the name of
the producer we just talked about that
with every one of them yes no that's
shelter's interns oh right and he's no
longer there Harvard senior fellow
interns who was the person at CNN just
recently they're under it was one of the
producers of Don lemon's show oh oh well
who could have guessed it yeah who would
have ever but criticism his campaign of
criticism he's basically just saying hey
I think he did a bad job of taking care
of this one area while you're here and
by the way here's your here's your PhD
thesis paper which seems he said it like
this it seems to advocate for underage
gay sex well not even that seems to it
just to suggest it should yeah
just like that but that's all we're
talking about is I've done bad Deeds now
they're being brought to light but
because they're being brought to light
I'm now the victim that's Joel Roth
right now well he believes that no good
deed goes unsexed if it's a 15 year old
boy hey fouchie right now is on CNN just
you know we'll go back to all the other
reasons
hospitals across the United States
overwhelmed by flu covid RSV cases don't
you love how they just blend in what
happened to the ticker of covet deaths
now flu is listed first let's hear what
the science has to say keep in mind
child sex offenders right producers at
CNN we only know the ones that we've
caught let's see what he has to say to
protect them their family and Society we
have a vaccine for flu and we're having
a pretty bad and early flu season if you
look at the traditional if only people
could have listened to Dr Rob McCullough
who was banned from Twitter from
Facebook our episode taken down when we
had him on before he went anywhere else
just to be clear if only someone could
have been saying if you keep doing this
you're going to have a horrible flu
season if only someone knew it when
fauci was the science you removed all of
them oh was was staying inside for so
long bad for your immune system to not
be out and with people oh who knew oh
it's a scientific thing I don't
understand I wouldn't have assumed that
myself no I know it's it's probably why
I kept traveling as a germaphobe don't
concern yourself with our science things
let's hear what he's saying mask
appropriate in an indoor setting shut up
about mandating anything I'm talking
about the common sense of when you go
into it's not a massive setting
particularly when you have a lot of
infection like that that you think about
the possibility of wearing a mask and
and one of them somewhat encouraging
things
RSV as bad as it is particularly for
young proven to not work elderly we have
peaked there it looks like it is
starting to come down so let's hope it
continues to have a trajectory down this
is the problem this is the problem of
having Hall monitors run your country
look there's some risk in life and at a
certain point you accept the risk no one
here is saying that covet wasn't real no
one hears saying that kovid was not uh
significantly more lethal to certain
demographics than the standard flu
particularly the elderly and the immune
compromise yeah no one here is saying
that we are just saying that people had
the right to make informed decisions
they had the right to hear from Dr
ramakala just as much as Elon Musk they
had the right to hear from those
practicing physicians in Los Angeles and
in Florida when those videos were
removed from all of social media because
part of what they were shouting from the
rooftops is exactly what's happening now
do you see the problem with limiting
speech do you see it it comes back to
bite you every single time okay let's
did you have something you wanted to say
the CNN producer you were asking about
before was John Griffin from uh Chris
Cuomo's old show he led he allegedly led
a perverted double life where he he was
part of a sorted BDSM ring that included
a child a nine-year-old girl
geez and he's also is Chris Cuomo's who
also led a perverted double life yeah
well he just grabbed and he just you
know smacked his secretary in the butt
or something he didn't the point is BDSM
with a nine-year-old girl allegedly
allegedly if it becomes that's different
if it becomes not allegedly let me ask
you this comment below if someone was
part of an underground sex ring right
with a nine-year-old girl this is a
question I want you to comment below
there are strength in numbers and by the
way let's keep it let's keep it I don't
want to say civil let's just not make it
any more filthy or aggressive okay sir
than it needs to be I want you to
comment below yes we'll just be let's I
want you to comment below genuinely here
if it's no longer allegedly
nine-year-old girl that's what you said
token Allen yeah nine-year-old girl BDSM
sex ring if it no longer becomes
allegedly meaning found guilty
death penalty
would you support that if it no longer
is allegedly legally is what I'm asking
you what do you think about people who
sexually abuse nine-year-old girls or
boys
if you're not willing to die on this
hill I pray to God that you don't have
kids anyway we go back to this Roth who
is an absolute piece of shh [ __ ] so
thank you we'll get this back on track
[Laughter]
ah here's reason number two so the guy
who supports pedophilia the guy who met
with U.S intelligence agencies by the
way the CIA remember how much child porn
they found on those computers we covered
that later not saying there's some
secret cabal of everyone who's a
pedophile commercial yeah we did what
I'm saying is there are enough
pedophiles and enough people who don't
have a problem with pedophilia and child
sex trafficking
who could do something about it in other
words here's the problem it's not that
someone is a pet that is a problem I
shouldn't say it's not that that is a
problem just because it's always a
problem problem
so I'm just says Ah not a problem no no
problem if you're a pedophile but the
real problem the more significant
problem I want to choose my words very
carefully here because I wouldn't want
to offend pedophiles the real problem
Beyond people being pedophiles or
advocating for it is people at
intelligence agencies
who could stop it
for example Larry Nasser it's people at
intelligence agencies who are tasked
with keeping you safe and you are told
to trust it's people in charge
of departments like Twitter trust and
safety
who are advocating for it so in other
words pedophilia right it's a very small
percentage of the population but you
only need a few of those people in
positions of power for it to have
catastrophic results like child porn
proliferating across Twitter oh and the
intelligence agencies don't do anything
about it you think you think Chris Cuomo
is going to cover this you think his
producer was going to put that into his
prep document this brings us to reason
number two oh we already hit it reason
number two Roth so this is pedophile to
begin with
he was also the person in charge of
censoring Hunter Biden laptop story
which I don't know if you know involved
sex with a minor
that softens the blow niece's feet yeah
something like that so this is what he
said about the story Mr Roth
given the severe risks here and lessons
of 2016 were airing on the side of
including a warning and preventing the
content from being Amplified okay you
did that with Hunter Biden and by the
way it was a U.S intelligence agencies
who told you that it was uh some kind of
a Russian hoax right Russian
disinformation campaign in hoax but I
understand that you want to air on the
side of safety that's your job including
a warning preventing the content from
being Amplified which is a fun word for
you know being told about right yes I
spoke about or letting people know but
here's the thing he's doing it for
safety hey so preventing it from being
Amplified preventing it from being
shared yeah
how about child porn
how about child porn oh no wait if we
bring it up it's a threat and then CNN
talks about what a victim you are that
other people are mad that you didn't put
the same labels or do your job to
protect children I say this as if you
are a dad and you are not Furious and
you know look I don't we do a lot of
stuff here and I'm not on board with the
rage porn
I am absolutely Furious
I am absolutely filled with rage that
this was going on
and I'm even more angry that we don't
know what's going on at Google at
YouTube at Facebook and Instagram that
we don't know we just know what we see
we know that we see content that isn't
age restricted which borders or is
outright pornography
are there people in charge like we now
know at Twitter and the FBI and the DHS
who are saying that's okay spend your
time throttling the hunter laptop story
it's the only instance ironically the
only instance where some form of
underage pornography might have actually
been throttled so hey you were accident
mentally less of a piece of [ __ ] Roth
which brings us to the number one reason
that this guy is a piece of human
excrement
obviously we know about Hunter Biden
yeah yeah okay that's pretty bad that
affected the outcome of the election
according to the polls we know that for
a fact if people move 100 laptop story
you still have president but for some
reason lots of Americans don't lots of
Americans do not
it's tough it's tough to find the story
if you have to scroll through
Oodles of pedophilic pornography I know
you only have so much time in the day so
Roth actually was very integral in
removing Trump the sitting president
from from Twitter
so he tried to find an excuse to flag
Trump's tweet about mail-in voting
here's what the Tweet was we read this
yesterday big big problems and
discrepancies with mail-in ballots all
over the USA must have final total on
November 3rd elephant we must just must
[Laughter]
and Roth's response in an internal
Twitter Channel was I agree with the
recommendation flagging right now with
leadership given that it's president of
the United States
can we use a new is it DOC P2 review
yeah
I don't know what that means yeah I P2
whatever again he's just trying to find
a way to do it right a minute ago when
he talked about the hunter Biden laptop
story he said given the extreme all caps
risk I'm sorry yeah the extreme risk of
putting that story out there there what
what extreme risk what are you talking
about and the lessons of 2016. I'm sorry
ahead of those two things go together Oh
you mean that Donald Trump got elected
the extreme risk is that Donald Trump
might win the presidency again yeah and
we learned our lesson in 2016 so
therefore we have to ban this is that
what you're saying because I don't
understand now you're looking at a very
benign tweet about the postal service
that you guys said was ruined by the joy
that was making everybody not be able to
get their votes in on time this is what
you guys said and now you're just trying
to find a way to ban him for it yeah
just any way you possibly can this this
is the most obvious clear election
meddling case that I've ever seen in my
life along with vagai yeah but at least
it wasn't you know a pet arrest so let
me just go here really quickly we have
uh this and you can hit the like button
hit the share button it helps with the
algorithm because YouTube wants you to
think we're dead certainly and we're
discussing an issue like this uh when
with proof yes
one more when addressing the Twitter
policy to uh to ban Trump here's what
Roth uh wrote and again all the
references are available I highly
recommend you read all the Twitter files
it says to put a different spin on it
policy is one part of the system of how
Twitter works the other part is me
that's exactly that's exactly like gay
pen Labyrinth eyes me
I'm the worst hope he gets the bottle
treatment I do
not seeing no it's a pen okay I'm joking
I'm joking joking figuratively of course
because it would be it would be wrong it
would be wrong I'll be wrong to uh have
any disdain for someone who Advocate
advocates for sex with children no
you've never won a bottle service they
get a drink yes bottle service Crystal
yeah his own table go query it's your
birthday now there are different things
you can change when you want to affect
different behaviors policy and
enforcement are one we ran into the
world changing faster than we were able
to either adapt the product or the
policy and by the way Donald Trump who
many in the many in the Republican side
I should say
it always does raise questions why so
many people who you think are your
allies dislike them I mean the reasons
that we disagree with them certainly had
nothing to do with the reasons that a
lot of other Republicans dislike them if
that makes sense Trump was aware of what
Roth was doing all the way back in May
2020 here's a clip uh here's one this is
our this is the Arbiter this guy is the
Arbiter of what's supposed to go on
Twitter he's the one he thought that he
thought in a huge CNN as a guide CNN
which is fake news he uses CNN as a
guide his name is yoel Roth and he's the
one that said that uh mail-in balloting
you look mail-in no fraud no fraud
really I need to take a look all over
the country there's cases all over the
country that's not true so here excuse
me I'm not finished so here's your uh
here's your man and that's on Twitter
boy what I've Loved for Donald Trump to
be out there and read his thesis or his
tweets here's the bed look here's the
bed he wrote gay dead and watch keep
watch kids excuse me he wants kids to
have sex with adults it's gross look at
this look at how gross excuse me excuse
me excuse me a lot of people have told
me that he thinks that otters I don't
know I don't know what that means in
audit but I do know that it means
apparently he wants to
do things that are frankly very not nice
not nice things with children that's we
have a problem we want people who don't
want to do nice things with children sir
that's not true excuse me why didn't he
read that we didn't have access to it
yep well and also whoever yelled that's
not true I think should have to go on to
the news channel tonight and read his
thesis yes I think I should have to walk
the plank yeah go ahead and say why is
it not true and go ahead and read what
he thinks and that's a reflection of the
spirit what he said is absolutely
unequivocally true what they would say
is you don't have proof
the New York Times while saying there's
two people saying that yeah it's it's
incredible to me so let me recap this
for you and then we're going to actually
discuss the drag queens who have been
invited to the Biden white house we're
going to do that on my club Only I'm
already angry I know but we'll do it on
mug Club only because that one even if
you can believe it is even worse than
this right now is this the world
sorry Merry Christmas
it's a Christmas miracle you know what I
want I want you to go down there to
Twitter Lane and bring him right here
with this yes 911 brought camaraderie
just kidding Jack I brought you a call
brought you a Christmas gift
put it there are the others pedophile
these are all notes to Peter asks
these are all grown-up pictures oh these
gag Pond pictures to the gay dating man
who's labeled Santa Claus that's his
handle yes that's otter Claus
you prefer Santa seal we could go all
day baby one I could go on forever baby
here's the deal I'm done Roth not only
do we know let's go through this hated
conservatives okay we know that colluded
with intelligence agencies to remove
conservatives sure specifically
conservatives who spoke out against
child sex trafficking we know that why
because he's a pervert who advocated for
underage people to have sex with adults
he's sorry he said underage teenagers to
have sex with adults and he also talked
about how sexy it was for him to have
pictures holding a child in his hairy
arms he wasn't he was invariably
involved with the censoring of all
conservatives with any major stories
including Hunter Biden laptop story
which intelligence agencies told him was
a part of a Russian disinformation
campaign which was echoed by all of the
media yeah mind you Andy was a key
player in Banning president Trump who
was then sitting president Trump by the
way wow you have leaders of other
countries Who currently have child
Brides I know he would prefer that they
have child husbands but you know what
he'll take the win where he can get them
he's allowed them to stay on Donald
Trump to be removed this is a guy who
was in charge of content at Twitter my
question to you is what is it that you
think exists at YouTube Google at
Facebook at Instagram no one has
purchased them you can comment below no
one has purchased them so we do not have
access because these are not these are
either private companies or their
companies where someone cannot go in and
audit the kind of content and let me
make one more thing clear here
and again look we just asked we don't
want to lose touch with you we have our
major announcement tomorrow mugclub
forever.com
that's the only reason we're able to
speak on all of these issues and our
goal is never to be removed but if we
speak the truth and we make sure that we
substantiate it we accept those
consequences we can do it because of you
I ask that you stick with us and that we
do not lose touch with you let's get
away from the idea of a stolen election
because of course you can't discuss that
of course you can't say that
intelligence agencies mainstream media
and those at Big Tech colluded to try
and alter the election you can't say
that you can't say that the hunter Biden
story would have actually altered the
outcome of the election except for the
fact that Biden voters themselves said
that it absolutely would you can't argue
right we we can't argue that for some
reason out there there's uh there are
groomers you're not allowed to talk
about that because it's a term that's no
longer allowed also the term woman is no
longer allowed the term Patriot is no
longer allowed but Donald Trump was
removed the hunter Biden laptop story
was removed people who criticized
Twitter's policy regarding child
pornography were removed people who were
conservative were removed I'm not
talking about a stolen election because
I would never say that look hey
you're now experiencing a stealing of
your country
let me put a fine point on it
do you believe the United States is a
country where those in power
support sex with children
if not there are enough not all of them
of course not but there are enough
people in positions of authority
who think that that should be a part of
the fabric of our country let's not talk
about an election you are having your
country stolen from you and to be clear
not talking about open borders though I
have a problem with that I'm not talking
about people coming on work visas I am
talking about people in positions of
power who have decided that values that
we have held since the beginning of the
founding of this country and by the way
all of Western Civilization that not
only should they no longer be a part
of our values not only should there be a
voice at the table
but that they shouldn't be uttered at
all because they're so offensive you
actually have to be banned one side is
arguing for free speech absolutism and I
get comes with like those black Hebrews
Hebrew Israelites we just discussed
right who said that they they like
Hitler I get there's bad that comes with
free speech absolutism the other side is
advocating for silencing of people who
are out there advocating for traditional
heteronormative marriages the nuclear
family
voter ID and believe in harsh
punishments for pedophiles they want
those people
removed how do I know check all the
references they remove them it's not
about a stolen election it's about a
stolen country and you know what I'm not
mad at people like this you can't be mad
at someone a snake for being a snake
aren't there people in positions of
power who share our values who can fight
back
why are we why are we the ones doing it
don't we need more effective fighters on
our side and I don't mean people just
going out being bad I don't mean being
an [ __ ] though you know what most of
us here are I'm okay with it where's our
people why did it take Elon Musk a
lifelong Democrat billionaire hey where
are all the billionaires who we know on
the right
Elon Musk did
it's no longer about a stolen election
it's about a stolen country and it's
about the people who can stop the theft
of our country
not doing a [ __ ] thing about it
mugclub forever.com don't let us lose
touch with you we are going to be back
of course tomorrow with far more to
discuss and you know what there'll be a
little more levity it's really weird you
would think that a guy who talks about
being a sex otter will be fodder for a
funnier show and instead everyone here
just wants to leave a us-shaped hole
through the wall
it's just it's too infuriating
um
YouTube you can piss off this has been
Joel Roth what a piece of [ __ ]
no no no no no no
no
no
no no
[Music]